October 28 1955 Bill Gates is born
William Henry Bill Gates the third was
born on October 28 1955 he and his two
sisters grew up in Seattle their father
William H Gates a second was a Seattle
attorney mary gates their late mother
was a schoolteacher University of
Washington region and chairwoman of the
United Way international 1967 to 1973
Bill Gates
attends lakeside prep school it was
during the spring term of 1968 at
Lakeside prep school the Bill Gates
first used a computer he Paul Allen and
several other students of which many
became Microsoft programmers became
addicted to the computer spending all
day and all night writing programs and
reading all the material that could get
their hands on in late 1968 the lakeside
programming group was formed consisting
of him Paul and two other students from
Lakeside prep school they wanted to
apply their new computer skills to the
real world they got this chance when the
computer center corporation struck a
deal with them in exchange her unlimited
computer time he and his friends
searched a computer for bugs and
weaknesses in the system 1973 bill gates
enrolls at Harvard University Bill Gates
started starting at Harvard University
in 1973 where he spent his time with
Paul Allen Gates and Allen worked on a
version of the programming language
basic that was the basis for the MIT's
Altair the first microcomputer available
he did not go on to graduate from
Harvard University as he left in his
junior year to start what was to become
the largest computer software company in
the world Microsoft Corporation April 4
1975 Bill Gates and Paul Allen formed
partnership called Microsoft Microsoft
was formed soon after the introduction
of the micro instrumentation and
telemetry systems MIT's Altair the first
personal computer a build-it-yourself
kit for hobbyists Bill Gates and Paul
Allen sees the opportunity to transform
this early PC into a breakthrough the
Altair needed software a programming
language that can make it perform useful
computing tasks that's where it all
began
over the years the PC has transformed
from a hobbyist toy to an indispensable
tool that continues to change the world
it had revolutionized how we deal with
information how we communicate and how
we work learn and play January 1st 1979
Microsoft moves headquarters to Bellevue
Washington
Microsoft became independent of mitts in
late 1976 and it continued to develop
programming language software for
various systems the company moved from
Albuquerque to its new home in Bellevue
Washington on January 1st 1979 during
Microsoft's early years all employees
had broad responsibility for the
company's business gates oversaw the
business details but continued to write
code as well in the first five years he
personally reviewed every line of code
the company shipped and often rewrote
parts of it as he saw fit 1980 Microsoft
partners with IBM to write basic for the
IBM PC in 1980 IBM approached Microsoft
to write the basic interpreter for its
upcoming personal computer the IBM PC
Gates proposed using 86-dos an operating
system similar to the one tim paterson
of seattle computing products SCP had
made for hardware similar to the pc
microsoft made a deal with SCP to become
the exclusive licensing agent and later
the full owner of 86-dos after adapting
the operating system for the pc
microsoft delivered it to IBM as pc das
in exchange for a one-time fee of
$50,000 Gates did not offer the transfer
the copyright on the operating system
because he believed that other hardware
vendors would clone IBM systems they did
and the sales of ms-dos made Microsoft a
major player in the industry
June 25th 1981 Microsoft becomes
incorporated and Bill Gates becomes
president Microsoft reorganized into a
privately held corporation with Bill
Gates as president and chairman of the
board and Paul Allen as executive vice
president Microsoft becomes microsoft
inc an incorporated business in the
state of Washington Microsoft launched
its first retail version of Microsoft
Windows on November 20th 1985
1989 Bill Gates found Corbis Gates
founded corpus and archive and art and
photography from public and private
collections corpus later becomes one of
the largest collections of visual
information in the world January 1st
1994 Bill Gates marries Melinda French
Bill & Melinda French gates were married
on January 1st 1994 they now have three
children May 18 1998 the United States
vs. Microsoft trial on May 18 1998 the
United States filed a civil complaint
alleging that Microsoft had engaged in
anti-competitive conduct in violation of
the Sherman Act the plaintiffs alleged
that Microsoft abused monopoly power on
intel-based computers in its handling of
operating system sales and web browser
sales the issue central to the case was
whether Microsoft was allowed to bundle
its flagship Internet Explorer web
browser software with as Microsoft
Windows operating system
bundling them together is alleged to
have been responsible for Microsoft's
victory in the browser Wars as every
Windows user had a copy of Internet
Explorer it was further alleged that
this unfairly restricted the market for
competing web browsers Microsoft stated
that the merchant of Microsoft Windows
and Internet Explorer was the result of
innovation and competition that the two
were now the same product and were
inextricably linked together and the
consumers were now getting all the
benefits of Internet Explorer for free
Microsoft vigorously defended itself in
the public arena arguing that his
attempts to innovate were under attack
by rival companies jealous of its
success and that government litigation
was merely their pawn judge Jackson
issued his findings of fact on November
5th 1999 which stated that Microsoft
constituted a monopoly and that
Microsoft had taken actions to crush
threats to that monopoly including Apple
Java Netscape Lotus Notes realnetworks
Linux and others then on April 3rd 2000
he issued a two-part ruling his
conclusions of law were that Microsoft
had committed mile Apple ization
attempted monopolization and tying in
violation of sections 1 & 2 of the
Sherman Act in his remedy was that
Microsoft must be broken into two
separate units one to produce the
operating system and want to produce
other software components
June 27 2008 bill gates steps down from
daily duties bill gates stepped down as
chief executive officer of Microsoft in
January of 2000 he remained as chairman
and created the position of chief
Software Architect in June 2006 Gates
announced that he would be transitioning
from full-time work at Microsoft to
part-time and full-time work at the Bill
and Melinda Gates Foundation he
gradually transferred his duties to Ray
Ozzie chief Software Architect and Craig
Mundy chief research and strategy
officer Gates's last full-time day at
Microsoft was June 27 2008 he remains at
Microsoft as non-executive chairman so
this is a new potential series on my
channel that I call time line where we
look at the timeline of a successful
entrepreneur and try to quickly tell
their story that hopefully inspires you
to dive deeper into the world I would
love to know what you think of this
video any feedback any comments do you
like the series can we make it better
please let me know put it in the comment
section below and if you want more bill
gates check out the top 10 rules video I
made on him the link is right there next
to me I think you'll enjoy continue to
believe and I'll see you there
when I started Microsoft I didn't think
of it as all that risky I mean I was so
excited about what we were doing
it's true I could have gone bankrupt